[Musik]
brandenburg das neue eldorado für öko
investoren
statt nachhaltiger solarförderung
entstehen hier immer mehr megapark für
solarzellen auf ackerflächen
energiewende auf kosten von bauern und
natur
[Musik]
blühende landschaften stadt blühende
landschaften das klingt nach
spitzeninvestments endlich wieder eine
wende die sich für investoren lohnt
solar wende
paradiesisch
wir haben die flächen wir haben wenig
einwohnerzahlen natürlich die sind ja
nicht doof die investoren hießen die
gelegenheit und hier kann man natürlich
erstmal quasi in die vollen gehen
jedenfalls denken dass sie investoren
zehn hektar ja nämlich das ist
ungeeignet hier wohnen werte sind die
signale die die bodenwerte sind zu hoch
der buga ist so fruchtbar ja das ist mir
wurscht dass sie ebenso schnell ist den
gemeinden ich habe den ganzen besitz
werden wir gerade einen ja schon
überschrieben an meiner tochter also
müssen noch mal ganz neu zwischenfall
[Gelächter]
sie haben ja gesehen dass er die sagt
voraus und was machte
[Gelächter]
leoni will mich nicht aber der bauern
nebenan hoffentlich mein geld das kann
ich hier mangels regulierung von bund
und ländern direkt an den mann bringen
cash mit klimawandel statt ernte auf dem
acker ich habe tolle nachricht ich kann
mir das gut vorstellen dass wir das hier
alles mit solarmodulen zu tackern und
dann springt dann hübsches sümmchen für
sie war aus herr voigt hat springt
heraus
das sümmchen wollen sie da schon ins
detail gehen oder ich bin mysterious
zukunft also und ich möchte nachhaltig
wirtschaften und deshalb gibt's bestimmt
leute jetzt machen wollen weil ich auch
verstehen kann ist lukrativ wie lange
wollen sie denn die flächen haben
so lange wie möglich
einfach jetzt komplett abkaufen hier
krise kommen sie eigentlich nach
brandenburg ja ich dachte hier kann man
die leute abzuzocken ich hab gehört dass
ich da einige schon bereit erklärt haben
und
vertrauen sich hierher zu fahren da
könnte ja auch mal konsequenzen haben
ich will keine konsequenzen ich will
rendite
ja wie sieht das aus ich will ja groß
einsteigen ins geschäft solarenergie
will hier direkt so ein paar k ich sag
mal zu bauen
die kommen wir ins geschäft
grundsätzlich wäre mir lieber sie würden
diese photovoltaik anlagen nicht auf den
acker stellen sondern so wie hier
beispielsweise auf einer militärischen
konversionsfläche wie viel haben sie
davon noch das ist sind die letzten elf
hektar wesentlich dafür zur verfügung
stellen dann geht ja noch ak
dann eben nicht sie müssen sich beeilen
werden noch käufer ist günstig es kaufen
wollen dann ist da der wildwuchs ist
eben auch da und entscheiden tun es die
gemeinden nicht wie bei windenergie dass
es eine planung gebe eine regionale die
gibt es bei solarparks nicht da kann
jeder überall hin
und im land wird fragen ob er seine
flächen nicht verpachten will und dann
bei der gemeinde versuchen eine
genehmigung zu bekommen ist es
kompliziert mit den ganzen anträgen wenn
ich so ein solarpark bauen will es ist
ein langwieriges verfahren das müssen
viele behörden beteiligt werden in
diesem plan verfahren
naturschutzbehörden kann ja sein dass da
auf dem auf den begehrten fläche der
grünen gebildete ringel wurm ist oder
irgendwas anders als alles was bisher
noch keiner wusste ich bin wirklich
überzeugt von meinen projekten spricht
also möglicherweise beeinflusst so ein
solarpark allein mit der sonne die mir
aus dem arsch scheint so euphorisiert
bin ich ja
aber was passiert wenn die sonne nicht
scheint also gut ich will das bild jetzt
nicht vertiefen um ganz schön aber es
ist tatsächlich so dass dass sich
investoren kommen und dann mit
präsentkörben ähnliches jetzt mal
versuchen so ein bisschen
überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten ja das ist
ganz plump aber das geschieht
tatsächlich das irgendwelchen
bürgermeistern gegen karubi werden die
die crew die bürgermeister geben diese
geschenke meistens zurück fremde sind
freunde die man noch nicht kennt und wie
gewinnt man freunde am besten durch ein
kleines geschenk nimmt es doch einfach
mal erst mal kriegt man sie gar nicht
herum fahren sie eigentlich nach dem
dreh fahren sie damit ihrem tesla wieder
zurück
tesla
jetzt nicht einfach so da musst du schon
was bei rumkommen ne wenn ja jetzt auch
kein idiot wie viele einwohner hat hat
die gemeinde sozusagen die gemeinde
gumtow hat 3500 einwohnern etwa gut aber
die könnte man ja umsiedeln ja zum
beispiel den hambacher vor holt gut was
macht der und jetzt hier was schnüffelt
er mir im schritt
keine ahnung
ja das ist doch toll aus aber das muss
natürlich alles weg die bäume müssen weg
der hund muss weg die ponys müssen weg
sie müssen weg und dann ist das ein
tolles geschäft da springt für uns was
tolles paar aus
so theoretisch ist alles geritzt jetzt
fehlt mir nur noch eins zum glück leoni
leoni ich liebe dich
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zu rissen mienen der stelle
[Musik]